Is it me or do you have a good ear? Maybe it's just an impression, but the song likes to relax the sound of people who talk to you about super captivating topics for hours. It sounds good, because I have something really interesting for you. The first mobility service by subscription to the country offered by the mobile audience. Yes, of course. At Star, you can subscribe to your 5G forfeiture without being attached. Mobile audience.
是我听错了吗，还是你的听力很好？也许这只是我的错觉，但歌曲总是喜欢让那些和你谈论数小时引人入胜话题的人放松下来。这听起来不错，因为我有一些非常有趣的事情要告诉你。由移动用户提供的全国首个移动订阅服务。是的，当然。在Star，你可以订阅你的5G套餐而无需绑定。移动用户。
To you, the difference. Or on our website. Teresa Marsden was incredibly close to her first born daughter, 20-year-old Renee. The two were more like best friends, and they told each other everything. Teresa had separated from Renee's biological father when Renee was just two years old, affording the mother and daughter a close bond. When Teresa eventually remarried a man named Mark and had three more children, Renee was delighted. Nurturing and kind-hearted, she loved being an older sister and adored her family.
对你来说，这是与众不同的。或者访问我们的网站。特蕾莎·马斯登（Teresa Marsden）与她的大女儿，20岁的蕾妮（Renee）非常亲近。两人更像是最好的朋友，她们无话不谈。特蕾莎在蕾妮两岁时就与蕾妮的亲生父亲分开了，这让母女俩建立了深厚的感情。当特蕾莎最终与一个名叫马克（Mark）的男人再婚并又生了三个孩子时，蕾妮感到非常高兴。她性格温和、心地善良，喜欢当姐姐，也非常爱她的家人。
She considered Mark to be her real father, as he raised her and was always there for her. Renee's life motto was, family comes first and everything else comes after. One Mother's Day, Renee presented Teresa with an unexpected surprise, a tattoo in her honour. Written down the side of Renee's ribcage were the words, life is beautiful because of you. When Renee arrived home early from work on the afternoon of Monday, August 5, 2013, Teresa could immediately sense that something was wrong. Renee was typically happy and bubbly with a bright infectious smile. But as she walked through the Marsden's living room at their home in Sydney's northwestern suburb of Glenhaven,
她把马克视为自己的亲生父亲，因为是他抚养她长大，并一直陪伴在她身边。蕾妮的人生格言是，家庭第一，其他一切排在后面。有一个母亲节，蕾妮给了特蕾莎一个意想不到的惊喜，一个为了纪念她的纹身。在蕾妮的肋骨侧面写着：“生命因你而美丽”。2013年8月5日星期一下午，当蕾妮提前下班回家时，特蕾莎立刻感觉到有些不对劲。蕾妮通常是快乐活泼的，带着灿烂而富有感染力的笑容。但当她走进位于悉尼西北郊区格伦黑文（Glenhaven）的马斯登家客厅时，
she was visibly deflated. Teresa asked Renee if everything was okay. Renee assured her mother that she was fine, before disappearing upstairs to her bedroom. Although Teresa instinctively knew that something was going on, she gave her daughter space. She trusted that Renee would talk to her when she was ready. Then, Teresa's phone beeped. It was a text message from Renee's boyfriend, Brayden Spatieri. It read,
她看起来明显很沮丧。特蕾莎问蕾妮是否一切都好。蕾妮向母亲保证她没事，然后上楼回到了自己的卧室。虽然特蕾莎凭直觉知道发生了什么事，但她还是给了女儿空间。她相信蕾妮准备好后会告诉她。这时，特蕾莎的手机响了。是一条来自蕾妮男友布雷登·斯帕蒂里（Brayden Spatieri）的短信。上面写着：
Sort your daughter out, threatening to kill herself. Renee Marsden was introduced to Brayden Spatieri in late November 2011 through her close friend, Camilla Zidane. Camilla and Brayden had dated in the past, but Camilla felt that Renee and Brayden were a more fitting match and she was more than happy to set them up. Camilla gave Renee Brayden's phone number and the two began exchanging text messages. Renee was immediately intrigued by Brayden. The 24-year-old came from a wealthy family and had attended one of Sydney's most prominent private schools. One of three children, he was already in the process of taking over his father's successful construction business, which specialized in high-rise buildings. Brayden took pride in his appearance, which was evident in his muscular physique and clean-cut dark hair.
管好你的女儿，她威胁要自杀。蕾妮·马斯登是在2011年11月下旬通过她的密友卡米拉·齐达内（Camilla Zidane）认识布雷登·斯帕蒂里的。卡米拉和布雷登过去曾约会过，但卡米拉觉得蕾妮和布雷登更般配，她非常乐意撮合他们。卡米拉给了蕾妮布雷登的电话号码，两人开始互发短信。蕾妮立刻被布雷登吸引了。这位24岁的年轻人来自一个富裕家庭，曾就读于悉尼最著名的私立学校之一。作为三个孩子中的一个，他已经在接手父亲成功的建筑生意，该生意专门从事高层建筑。布雷登以自己的外表为荣，这从他肌肉发达的体格和干净利落的深色头发中显而易见。
A photo Camilla had of her and Brayden together captured his warm smile as Camilla rested her head on his shoulder. Like Renee, Brayden also had clear goals for his life that revolved around marriage and starting a family. There was just one problem. Not long before Brayden and Renee began texting, Brayden had been involved in a motorcycle accident that resulted in the death of his best friend. He'd been anxiously awaiting a court date and when the day came, he was convicted of manslaughter and sentenced to two years in Gulburn Prison, located two hours south of Sydney. Renee was devastated that the two didn't get the chance to meet before Brayden's conviction, but he reassured her that the time would go fast. He'd be out before her 21st birthday and they could see how things panned out then. In the meantime, their relationship didn't have to come to a standstill.
卡米拉有一张她和布雷登的合影，捕捉到了他温暖的笑容，卡米拉把头靠在他的肩膀上。像蕾妮一样，布雷登对生活也有明确的目标，那就是结婚和组建家庭。只有一个问题。在布雷登和蕾妮开始发短信前不久，布雷登卷入了一场摩托车事故，导致他最好的朋友死亡。他一直焦急地等待着开庭日期，当那一天到来时，他被判过失杀人罪，并被判处在悉尼以南两小时车程的古尔本监狱（Gulburn Prison）服刑两年。蕾妮对两人在布雷登入狱前没能见面感到非常难过，但他向她保证时间会过得很快。他会在她21岁生日之前出来，到时候他们可以看看事情会如何发展。在此期间，他们的关系不必停滞不前。
With his lawyer's help, Brayden managed to sneak a mobile phone into his cell. He couldn't risk speaking on it in case anyone overheard him, but he could continue messaging Renee in secret via text and on social media. As for their first real-life meeting, that would have to wait. Brayden had broken a deal in which he agreed to forego visitation rights in exchange for a reduced sentence. Renee and Brayden kept in close contact and their feelings towards one another continued to grow. They messaged each other daily and it wasn't long before their friendship turned into a romance. When Renee told her mother about Brayden, Theresa was taken aback. Renee had only recently come out of a serious relationship with her boyfriend Angus and Theresa wondered if it was too soon to enter into something else.
在律师的帮助下，布雷登设法偷偷把一部手机带进了牢房。他不敢在电话里说话，以免被别人听到，但他可以通过短信和社交媒体秘密地继续与蕾妮联系。至于他们第一次现实生活中的见面，那只能再等等了。布雷登违反了一项协议，即他同意放弃探视权以换取减刑。蕾妮和布雷登保持着密切联系，他们对彼此的感情不断加深。他们每天互发信息，没过多久，他们的友谊就变成了浪漫的爱情。当蕾妮告诉母亲关于布雷登的事时，特蕾莎感到很吃惊。蕾妮最近才刚结束与男友安格斯（Angus）的一段认真关系，特蕾莎想知道现在开始另一段感情是否太快了。
She was also concerned about Brayden being in jail, but she kept those opinions to herself. The last thing she wanted was to drive a wedge between herself and her daughter. Renee could be a hopeless romantic, but she was also smart and Theresa trusted her judgment. At the end of the day, she just wanted Renee to be happy. Other friends and family members also questioned whether the relationship was a good idea, but by December, Renee was completely smitten. While she understood the criticism, it was difficult for her not to take it to heart. Brayden reached out to Theresa directly to reassure her of his good intentions. He wrote, Renee is upset because everyone keeps telling her the obvious that I'm in jail and it will never work.
她也担心布雷登在坐牢，但她把这些想法藏在心里。她最不想做的就是让自己和女儿之间产生隔阂。蕾妮可能是一个无可救药的浪漫主义者，但她也很聪明，特蕾莎相信她的判断。归根结底，她只是希望蕾妮幸福。其他朋友和家人也质疑这段关系是否是个好主意，但到了12月，蕾妮已经完全被迷住了。虽然她理解这些批评，但她很难不往心里去。布雷登直接联系了特蕾莎，向她保证自己的诚意。他写道：“蕾妮很难过，因为每个人都在告诉她显而易见的事实，那就是我在坐牢，这永远不会有结果。”
She is everything to me and the last thing I want is to hold her down. She chose to go through this with me and after everything that happened she became my best friend. I have fallen for her and she tells me she feels the same. Theresa, I'm a good guy. I would never disrespect her, cheat or lie to her. She is everything to me and I could make her more than happy. Renee and Brayden began discussing their life together on the outside. Their feelings towards one another were intense and they didn't hold back with expressing how they felt. Brayden sent Renee flowers, cards and gifts and just three months after they began texting, Renee visited a tadupala with her friend Camilla.
“她是我的一切，我最不想做的就是拖累她。她选择和我一起经历这一切，在发生所有事情之后，她成了我最好的朋友。我已经爱上了她，她说她也有同样的感觉。特蕾莎，我是个好人。我永远不会不尊重她，欺骗她或对她撒谎。她是我的一切，我可以让她比任何人都幸福。”蕾妮和布雷登开始讨论他们在监狱外的生活。他们对彼此的感情很强烈，表达起来毫不保留。布雷登给蕾妮送了花、卡片和礼物，在他们开始发短信仅仅三个月后，蕾妮就和她的朋友卡米拉一起去纹身了。
Solidifying her love for Brayden with a permanent tribute, she had the name B Spatieri inked into the right side of her chest. On New Year's Eve of 2011, Renee was looking forward to a night out clubbing. She wore a red dress for the occasion and snapped a quick photo to send to Brayden. Rather than complimenting her, he said the dress was too revealing and warned that she better not cheat on him. Throughout the evening, he bombarded Renee with the jealous text messages. After this, another side of Brayden started to emerge. In early April 2012, Renee's mother, Theresa, was scrolling through Facebook when she came across a post made by Renee's ex-boyfriend, Angus. Theresa had always been fond of Angus so she liked the post.
为了用永久的纪念来巩固她对布雷登的爱，她在胸部右侧纹上了“B Spatieri”的名字。2011年除夕夜，蕾妮期待着去夜店狂欢。她为此穿了一件红色的裙子，并拍了一张快照发给布雷登。他没有夸奖她，反而说裙子太暴露了，并警告她最好不要背叛他。整个晚上，他用嫉妒的短信轰炸蕾妮。此后，布雷登的另一面开始显露出来。2012年4月初，蕾妮的母亲特蕾莎在浏览Facebook时，偶然看到了蕾妮的前男友安格斯发布的一条帖子。特蕾莎一直很喜欢安格斯，所以她给那条帖子点了赞。
Brayden had access to Renee's Facebook account and when he saw the engagement from Theresa, he was furious. He hated that she was still communicating with Renee's ex and contacted Renee to express how much this hurt him. He then sent Theresa an abusive text message accusing her of being an unfit mother. Theresa was appalled not only by the accusation but by the fact that Renee had given Brayden her Facebook password. Shortly after, Brayden underwent surgery which required several weeks of recovery. He wasn't able to use his phone during that time but his lawyer contacted Renee to let her know that the operation had been a success. By May, Theresa could no longer bite her tongue. She told Renee she found Brayden to be rude and arrogant and didn't think theirs was a healthy relationship.
布雷登可以访问蕾妮的Facebook账户，当他看到特蕾莎的互动时，他非常愤怒。他讨厌她还在和蕾妮的前男友交流，并联系蕾妮表达了这让他有多受伤。然后，他给特蕾莎发了一条辱骂性的短信，指责她是一个不称职的母亲。特蕾莎不仅对这种指责感到震惊，而且对蕾妮把Facebook密码给了布雷登这一事实感到震惊。不久之后，布雷登接受了手术，需要几周的恢复期。在那段时间里他无法使用手机，但他的律师联系了蕾妮，让她知道手术很成功。到了5月，特蕾莎再也无法保持沉默了。她告诉蕾妮，她觉得布雷登粗鲁且傲慢，认为他们的关系不健康。
Renee valued her mother's opinion and agreed to end the romantic relationship while still supporting Brayden as a friend. In August 2012, Brayden applied for parole and succeeded. Renee was relieved that the two would finally be able to meet in person but the feeling was short-lived. Shortly after Brayden's release, he got into an altercation with his father who filed assault charges against him. Brayden was back behind bars almost as quickly as he'd been let out and Renee was absolutely crushed. Theresa was becoming increasingly concerned about the impact that Brayden's incarceration was having on her daughter. Privately, she thought Renee deserved better. Theresa reached out to Brayden and requested that he cease contact with Renee at least until he was a free man.
蕾妮重视母亲的意见，并同意结束恋爱关系，但仍以朋友身份支持布雷登。2012年8月，布雷登申请假释并获得成功。蕾妮很欣慰两人终于可以见面了，但这种感觉很短暂。布雷登获释后不久，他与父亲发生了争执，父亲对他提起了袭击指控。布雷登几乎在他被释放的同时又回到了监狱，蕾妮彻底崩溃了。特蕾莎越来越担心布雷登的监禁对她女儿的影响。私下里，她认为蕾妮值得更好的。特蕾莎联系了布雷登，要求他停止与蕾妮联系，至少在他重获自由之前。
Brayden reluctantly agreed. He told Renee to move on for the time being but reassured her that his feelings hadn't changed and they could start things up again when he was on the outside. Renee tried to move on but the lack of contact with Brayden left a void in her life. She was also going through a stressful situation at work and it all became too much. Renee took an overdose of medication and while she didn't intend to harm herself, the dose made her sick. For several days she was nauseous and couldn't keep any food down. She eventually went to the emergency room where she told the attending doctor that she regretted the overdose. She was happy to be alive and had no lingering feelings of self-harm.
布雷登勉强同意了。他告诉蕾妮暂时放下这段感情，但向她保证他的感情没有改变，等他出来后他们可以重新开始。蕾妮试图放下，但与布雷登失去联系让她的生活出现了一个空洞。她在工作中也经历着压力，这一切变得难以承受。蕾妮服用过量药物，虽然她并不打算伤害自己，但剂量让她生病了。几天来她一直恶心，吃不下任何东西。她最终去了急诊室，告诉主治医生她后悔服药过量。她很高兴自己还活着，没有任何自残的念头。
With no damage done, she was discharged that same day. This signalled a turning point for Renee. She started dating a co-worker named Ian who was 12 years her senior. Despite the age gap, Renee's parents were thrilled. Ian was a decent man who treated Renee well and made her happy. But the pair's relationship wasn't without complications. When Brayden found out about Ian, he raged. He managed to get Ian's contact details and sent him a message that warned,
由于没有造成伤害，她当天就出院了。这对蕾妮来说是一个转折点。她开始和一位比她大12岁的同事伊恩（Ian）约会。尽管有年龄差距，蕾妮的父母还是很高兴。伊恩是一个正派的人，对蕾妮很好，让她很开心。但两人的关系并非没有波折。当布雷登发现伊恩的存在时，他暴跳如雷。他设法弄到了伊恩的联系方式，并给他发了一条警告信息：
stay the fuck away from Renee. In October 2012, Renee attended an awards ceremony for work. Dolled up in a new dress, she took a photo of herself in her hotel room and posted it on social media. Shortly after, she received a message from Brayden. He had seen the post and made the astute observation that Ian's shoes were visible in the photo. This enraged Brayden, who began accusing Renee of cheating on him. Renee's relationship with Ian continued to progress, but she resumed regular contact with Brayden. Ian knew that the two were still in touch and although he wasn't happy about it, he seemingly accepted it.
“离蕾妮远点。”2012年10月，蕾妮参加了一个工作颁奖典礼。她穿着一件新裙子，在酒店房间里拍了一张照片并发布在社交媒体上。不久之后，她收到了布雷登的消息。他看到了那条帖子，并敏锐地观察到照片中露出了伊恩的鞋子。这激怒了布雷登，他开始指责蕾妮背叛他。蕾妮与伊恩的关系继续发展，但她恢复了与布雷登的定期联系。伊恩知道两人仍有联系，虽然他不高兴，但他似乎接受了。
In December, Renee and Ian were attending a Christmas function for work, after which they intended to go to the casino. Ian's phone vibrated. It was a text message from Brayden. You better be careful, it read. I'll be at the casino tonight, watching you. By January 2013, Renee and Ian were engaged, but Renee still maintained contact with Brayden. It had become a big problem in her and Ian's relationship, with Brayden continuing to send threatening messages to Ian warning him to stay away. Brayden made it very clear to Ian that he also intended to marry Renee.
12月，蕾妮和伊恩参加了一个工作圣诞聚会，之后他们打算去赌场。伊恩的手机震动了。是布雷登发来的短信。“你最好小心点，”上面写着，“我今晚会在赌场，盯着你。”到了2013年1月，蕾妮和伊恩订婚了，但蕾妮仍然与布雷登保持联系。这成了她和伊恩关系中的一个大问题，布雷登继续给伊恩发送威胁信息，警告他离远点。布雷登向伊恩明确表示，他也打算娶蕾妮。
Eventually, Ian had enough. In March, he gave Renee an ultimatum that was either him or Brayden. Renee agonized over the decision, but eventually made up her mind. She chose Brayden. It was a rocky transition as the two worked to rebuild their relationship and serious cracks began to form. One day they were loving and supportive of one another, and the next they were arguing. Brayden told Renee he wasn't sure if he still wanted to take over his father's construction business, which she thought was a mistake. In turn, he accused her of being greedy and only caring about money. He also pressed her about her relationship with Ian, which he viewed as infidelity, and this deeply frustrated Renee.
最终，伊恩受够了。3月，他给蕾妮下了最后通牒，要么选他，要么选布雷登。蕾妮对这个决定感到痛苦，但最终下定了决心。她选择了布雷登。这是一个艰难的过渡，两人努力重建关系，严重的裂痕开始形成。有一天他们还相爱并互相支持，第二天他们就在争吵。布雷登告诉蕾妮，他不确定是否还想接手父亲的建筑生意，她认为这是一个错误。反过来，他指责她贪婪，只关心钱。他还逼问她与伊恩的关系，他将其视为不忠，这让蕾妮深感沮丧。
Whenever they fought, it was usually resolved by Renee apologizing and pacifying Brayden's concerns. But there was one thing that Renee couldn't move past. By mid-April 2013, the two had been in an on and off relationship for one and a half years, and she still had no tangible piece of Brayden. There had been gifts and a small number of cropped selfies showing Brayden's muscular torso, but she wanted something of his she could hold. Brayden had previously told Renee that all of his personal belongings were locked up in a storage unit, so she began asking if she could get hold of the key. When Brayden rejected the request, Renee was floored. She reminded Brayden of everything that she'd done for him, and asked that he make the same effort. In a series of text messages, Renee wrote,
每当他们吵架时，通常都是以蕾妮道歉并安抚布雷登的担忧而告终。但有一件事蕾妮无法释怀。到2013年4月中旬，两人断断续续地交往了一年半，她仍然没有布雷登的任何实物。虽然有一些礼物和少量显示布雷登肌肉躯干的裁剪自拍照，但她想要一些属于他的、她可以握在手里的东西。布雷登之前告诉蕾妮，他所有的个人物品都锁在一个储物单元里，所以她开始询问是否能拿到钥匙。当布雷登拒绝了这个请求时，蕾妮惊呆了。她提醒布雷登她为他所做的一切，并要求他做出同样的努力。在一系列短信中，蕾妮写道：
I asked you for one simple thing, a key. Not money, not to escape jail. Nothing but a key. Brayden, I have nothing of you. Absolutely nothing. I can't even get a photo off you anymore. It's hard for me, Brayden, okay? It's killing me. In regards to visiting the storage unit, she wrote, I don't need anyone with me. I want to go by myself, just to touch something you have, or see. It would mean more than the world to me, just that once to go. Still, Brayden said no. When Renee persisted, he accused her of being a quote, materialistic bitch,
“我只向你要了一件简单的事，一把钥匙。不是钱，不是为了逃离监狱。除了钥匙什么都不要。布雷登，我什么都没有你的。什么都没有。我甚至不能再从你那里得到一张照片了。这对我来说很难，布雷登，好吗？这快把我逼疯了。”关于去储物单元，她写道：“我不需要任何人陪我。我想自己去，只是为了触摸一下你拥有的东西，或者看看。那对我来说意义重大，就去那一次。”然而，布雷登还是拒绝了。当蕾妮坚持时，他指责她是一个“物质主义的婊子”，
and threatened to sell everything in the storage unit just so she would shut up about it. Adding to the tension was Renee's ongoing request to visit Brayden's lawyer. Brayden had been having trouble with his phone, so Renee wanted to give him a new one. Given that she wasn't allowed to visit him in jail, she hoped Brayden's lawyer could bring it to him on her behalf. Renee was also considering studying forensic science at Sydney University, but before she made any concrete plans, she wanted to know more about Brayden's possible relay state. Brayden said this wasn't possible, as he didn't know where his lawyer worked from. Renee found this hard to believe.
并威胁要卖掉储物单元里的所有东西，好让她闭嘴。加剧紧张局势的是蕾妮不断要求去见布雷登的律师。布雷登的手机一直有问题，所以蕾妮想给他一部新的。鉴于她不被允许在监狱里探视他，她希望布雷登的律师能代她带给他。蕾妮还在考虑在悉尼大学学习法医科学，但在做出任何具体计划之前，她想更多地了解布雷登可能的假释状态。布雷登说这不可能，因为他不知道他的律师在哪里办公。蕾妮觉得这很难相信。
She knew that Brayden had attended multiple meetings with his lawyer, so she questioned it. Brayden responded, Who the fuck are you to question what my meetings are about and fucking who with? This was the last straw for Renee. She told Brayden she'd had enough. He quickly backtracked, texting her an apology that read, I love you Renee, you changed my life from day one. I know there has been hard times, fucked times and mean times.
她知道布雷登曾多次与他的律师会面，所以她对此表示质疑。布雷登回应道：“你他妈是谁啊，敢质疑我的会议是关于什么的，又他妈是和谁开的？”这是蕾妮的最后底线。她告诉布雷登她受够了。他很快改变了态度，给她发了一条道歉短信，上面写着：“我爱你，蕾妮，从第一天起你就改变了我的生活。我知道有过艰难的时刻，糟糕的时刻和刻薄的时刻。”
I adore you and you're so beautiful in every way. I miss you, I love you so much Renee, without fail, every day. Renee said she was done with the relationship unless Brayden changed his behaviour and agreed to her simple requests. Brayden explained he just wasn't ready to face what was in the storage unit. He pleaded for Renee to have faith in him and to stop questioning him, the same way he'd agreed to stop questioning her about Ian. They had to learn to believe in one another. Justifying his behaviour, Brayden texted, I fucking love you more than you know, that's why I get so angry when you question me.
“我崇拜你，你在各方面都那么美丽。我想你，我太爱你了，蕾妮，毫无疑问，每一天。”蕾妮说，除非布雷登改变他的行为并同意她简单的要求，否则她就结束这段关系。布雷登解释说他只是还没准备好面对储物单元里的东西。他恳求蕾妮对他有信心，停止质疑他，就像他同意停止质疑她和伊恩的关系一样。他们必须学会相信彼此。为了证明自己的行为合理，布雷登发短信说：“我他妈爱你胜过你知道的，这就是为什么当你质疑我时我会那么生气。”
Renee eventually softened and by late May 2013 their relationship reached a peak. They talked about marriage and their plans for a honeymoon in Greece. Brayden texted Renee, We will have the best wedding baby, I'll make you happy. I'll do whatever you want, just for you. I want you to be mine forever and be mine for the rest of my life. I want to be your husband and you be my wife. I adore you.
蕾妮最终心软了，到2013年5月下旬，他们的关系达到了顶峰。他们谈论了婚姻和去希腊度蜜月的计划。布雷登给蕾妮发短信说：“我们会有一个最好的婚礼，宝贝，我会让你幸福。我会做任何你想要的，只为你。我想让你永远属于我，余生都属于我。我想成为你的丈夫，你成为我的妻子。我崇拜你。”
But the hire was short lived. Renee had recently started a new job as a receptionist for a logistics company and Brayden was jealous about the time she was spending with her new co-workers. A few days after discussing their wedding plans, Brayden asked Renee what she'd been up to and she said she hadn't left the house. Brayden knew this was a lie. He admitted he'd installed tracking software on Renee's phone and could see that she'd gone to the gym. He said he could no longer trust her, the relationship was over. The only way he'd consider forgiving Renee was if she stopped socializing with her work colleagues. Renee apologized profusely, but the argument continued for days until she eventually told Brayden she no longer wanted to marry him.
但这种快乐是短暂的。蕾妮最近在一家物流公司找到了一份接待员的新工作，布雷登对她花时间与新同事相处感到嫉妒。在讨论婚礼计划几天后，布雷登问蕾妮在做什么，她说她没出过门。布雷登知道这是谎言。他承认他在蕾妮的手机上安装了追踪软件，可以看到她去了健身房。他说他再也不能信任她了，这段关系结束了。他考虑原谅蕾妮的唯一方法是她停止与同事社交。蕾妮不停地道歉，但争吵持续了几天，直到她最终告诉布雷登她不想再嫁给他了。
She'd only reconsider if he agreed to make a list of eight changes she'd identified as problematic. Brayden agreed, as long as Renee promised to remain loyal and agreed not to spend time alone with her male colleagues. By mid-June, their relationship was back on track. Brayden's parole date was looming and the pair were optimistic about the future. Brayden told Renee, You're the best thing that ever happened to me. Renee responded, No baby, we're the best thing that has ever happened to each other. We define true love.
她只有在他同意列出她认为有问题的八项改变时才会重新考虑。布雷登同意了，只要蕾妮承诺保持忠诚，并同意不与男性同事单独相处。到6月中旬，他们的关系回到了正轨。布雷登的假释日期临近，两人对未来充满乐观。布雷登告诉蕾妮：“你是我发生过的最好的事情。”蕾妮回应道：“不，宝贝，我们是彼此发生过的最好的事情。我们定义了真爱。”
We haven't met, we haven't held each other, we haven't done anything together. Yet we love each other more than anything. We have a family and we have our life planned. In the lead up to Brayden's parole, he informed Renee that he wouldn't have access to his phone for a whole month. Being out of contact was hard for Renee, but she used it as a period of reflection. On July 22, she wrote a letter to Brayden she hoped to give to him later on. It read in part, This time away has made me realise we argue over stupid things too often and it's pointless.
“我们没见过面，没拥抱过，没一起做过任何事。然而我们比任何人都爱对方。我们有一个家庭，我们规划了我们的生活。”在布雷登假释前夕，他通知蕾妮，他将有一个月的时间无法使用手机。失去联系对蕾妮来说很艰难，但她把它当作一个反思期。7月22日，她给布雷登写了一封信，希望以后能交给他。信中部分写道：“这段分开的时间让我意识到我们太频繁地为愚蠢的事情争吵，这毫无意义。”
I love you beyond words and I'll never let you go. I can't be without you. Baby, you're my rock, my hero, my everything and I'll love and cherish you all the days of our lives together. I can't wait to be your wife and to give you the happiness you deserve. Even though Renee wasn't sure when Brayden would have access to his phone again, she texted him every day in the hopes of receiving a reply. By the morning of Monday, August 5, 2013, over a month had passed with no word from him. The silence was starting to take a toll on Renee.
“我爱你胜过言语，我永远不会让你走。没有你我活不下去。宝贝，你是我的支柱，我的英雄，我的一切，我会爱并珍惜我们在一起的每一天。我迫不及待想成为你的妻子，给你应得的幸福。”尽管蕾妮不确定布雷登何时能再次使用手机，但她每天都给他发短信，希望能收到回复。到了2013年8月5日星期一早上，已经过去了一个多月，还是没有他的消息。这种沉默开始对蕾妮造成影响。
She told her work colleague Joseph what was going on and the two arranged to have lunch together later that day. Just before midday, Renee finally received a text from Brayden. They began messaging back and forth but they weren't the warm affectionate messages Renee had been expecting. She emailed Joseph saying she was upset because Brayden was being blunt. The couple continued texting until Renee's lunch break rolled around at 1pm. As she and Joseph began walking to a nearby coffee shop, Renee received another message. Her hands began to shake and she started to cry. She showed the phone to Joseph.
她告诉同事约瑟夫（Joseph）发生了什么事，两人安排当天晚些时候一起吃午饭。中午前不久，蕾妮终于收到了布雷登的短信。他们开始互发信息，但那并不是蕾妮所期待的温暖而深情的短信。她给约瑟夫发邮件说她很难过，因为布雷登说话很生硬。这对情侣继续发短信，直到蕾妮下午1点的午休时间到了。当她和约瑟夫开始走向附近的一家咖啡店时，蕾妮收到了另一条消息。她的手开始颤抖，她开始哭泣。她把手机给约瑟夫看。
The message was from Brayden and read, I think I need a break and so do you. Renee and Joseph continued on to the coffee shop but Renee was beside herself. She sent Brayden a bunch of messages but he didn't reply. Renee was too upset to return to work. She went home where her mother Teresa instantly noticed that something was wrong. Renee assured her mother she was fine before retreating to her room. Teresa then received the text from Brayden saying that her daughter was threatening suicide.
信息来自布雷登，上面写着：“我想我需要休息一下，你也一样。”蕾妮和约瑟夫继续前往咖啡店，但蕾妮已经崩溃了。她给布雷登发了一堆信息，但他没有回复。蕾妮太难过了，无法回到工作岗位。她回到家，母亲特蕾莎立刻注意到有些不对劲。蕾妮向母亲保证她没事，然后退回了自己的房间。特蕾莎随后收到了布雷登的短信，说她的女儿威胁要自杀。
Teresa responded, Please explain to me why a young woman would want to kill herself. To which Brayden said, Ask her yourself. Maybe explain to me why you never got her help last time. Have you ever thought you have neglected her when she clearly needs help? Teresa went straight up to Renee's bedroom and showed her the messages from Brayden. She asked whether she should be concerned.
特蕾莎回复道：“请向我解释为什么一个年轻女子会想自杀。”布雷登说：“你自己问她吧。也许向我解释一下为什么上次你没帮她。你有没有想过，当她明显需要帮助时，你忽视了她？”特蕾莎直接走到蕾妮的卧室，给蕾妮看了布雷登发来的信息。她问自己是否应该担心。
Renee responded, Don't be stupid mum, I've finally found out what he's all about. You don't have to worry about him anymore mum, it's over. Teresa left her daughter alone but went back to check on her shortly after. Renee was getting changed into black tights, a black jumper and black ballet flats. She applied some fresh makeup and pulled her long hair back into a bun. Renee said she was going out to dinner with some work friends in the eastern suburbs but wouldn't be out long. Bray assured that Renee was feeling better, Teresa left home to take two of her younger children to swimming lessons.
蕾妮回答说：“别傻了，妈妈，我终于发现他是什么样的人了。你不用再担心他了，妈妈，结束了。”特蕾莎让女儿一个人待着，但不久后又回去查看她。蕾妮正在换上黑色紧身裤、黑色套头衫和黑色芭蕾平底鞋。她补了点妆，把长发扎成了一个发髻。蕾妮说她要和一些工作朋友去东郊吃晚饭，但不会出去太久。确信蕾妮感觉好些了，特蕾莎离开家带两个年幼的孩子去上游泳课。
While she was there, her phone beeped at 5.49pm. It was a message from Renee. I love you so much, it said. I'm sorry for everything and the pain I will now cause you but I'll be okay, I'll still be here. When you need to talk to me just call my name and I'll be there. You're the most amazing person and mother ever and my very best friend. I wasn't happy and I need you to understand that it's okay. Don't let this ruin everything else you need to take care of, I need you to be strong for me.
当她在那里时，她的手机在下午5点49分响了。是蕾妮发来的信息。“我太爱你了，”上面写着，“对不起，为了这一切，也为了我现在会带给你的痛苦，但我会没事的，我还会在这里。当你需要和我说话时，只要叫我的名字，我就会在那里。你是最了不起的人和母亲，也是我最好的朋友。我不快乐，我需要你明白这没关系。不要让这毁掉你需要照顾的其他一切，我需要你为我坚强。”
I love you mumma, I always will and I'll be waiting when you come. Teresa wasn't entirely sure what to make of her daughter's text message. It wasn't out of character for Renee to send her affectionate texts but this one was significantly different. Teresa called Renee's phone multiple times but there was no answer. She went and showed the text to a friend who suggested that she call the police. Officers arrived at the Marston's house at 7.50pm and were immediately concerned for Renee's welfare. They put an alert out for Renee's car, a red Mazda 2, and started patrolling the streets on the lookout for the 20-year-old. Meanwhile, Teresa texted Renee's friend, Camilla Zidane, and asked if she'd heard from Renee.
“我爱你，妈妈，我永远都会，当你来的时候我会等着。”特蕾莎不太确定该如何理解女儿的短信。蕾妮发深情的短信并不反常，但这一条明显不同。特蕾莎多次拨打蕾妮的电话，但无人接听。她去把短信给一位朋友看，朋友建议她报警。警察在晚上7点50分到达马斯登家，并立即对蕾妮的安危表示担忧。他们对蕾妮的车，一辆红色马自达2，发出了警报，并开始在街上巡逻，寻找这位20岁的年轻人。与此同时，特蕾莎给蕾妮的朋友卡米拉·齐达内发短信，询问她是否收到蕾妮的消息。
The two friends had recently had a falling out but Teresa knew they usually patched things up. Camilla responded, she messaged me a while ago, is everything okay? Camilla later said she'd received a message from Renee just minutes before Teresa had. In it, Renee said that she loved Camilla and was sorry. Given that they weren't speaking, Camilla assumed the text was in relation to their falling out. She offered to come over and help Teresa look for Renee. They drove around to various locations where Camilla thought her friend might be, including a nearby McDonald's. It then occurred to Camilla that Renee might have gone to Braden's sister's house.
这两个朋友最近闹翻了，但特蕾莎知道她们通常会和好。卡米拉回复说：“她不久前给我发了信息，一切都好吗？”卡米拉后来表示，她在特蕾莎收到信息前几分钟就收到了蕾妮的信息。在信息中，蕾妮说她爱卡米拉，并表示抱歉。鉴于她们当时没说话，卡米拉以为短信是关于她们闹翻的事。她主动提出过来帮特蕾莎寻找蕾妮。她们开车去了卡米拉认为她朋友可能在的各个地方，包括附近的一家麦当劳。卡米拉随后想到蕾妮可能去了布雷登姐姐家。
Camilla directed them to a residence in Glenhaven, but when they drove by, Renee's car was nowhere to be seen. The police contacted Renee's mobile phone provider, who informed them that her phone had been switched off just before 6pm in the vicinity of Vor Clues, a Sydney suburb 40km east of the Mazda's home. This location raised immediate red flags for police. Vor Clues was the gateway to the Gap, a high ocean cliff top on the South Head Peninsula. Due to its views over the Tasman Sea, the area was a popular tourist destination, but it was also a notorious suicide spot. Measures had been put in place to deter those considering ending their own lives, including an in-wood leaning concave barrier, security cameras, and phone booths providing access to 24-7 crisis counselling.
卡米拉指引她们去了格伦黑文的一处住所，但当她们开车经过时，蕾妮的车不见踪影。警方联系了蕾妮的移动电话运营商，对方告知他们，她的手机在下午6点前不久在沃克卢斯（Vaucluse）附近被关机，这是一个位于马斯登家以东40公里的悉尼郊区。这个地点引起了警方的立即警觉。沃克卢斯是“缺口”（The Gap）的门户，这是一个位于南角半岛的高耸海崖。由于其俯瞰塔斯曼海的景色，该地区是一个受欢迎的旅游目的地，但它也是一个臭名昭著的自杀点。为了阻止那些考虑结束自己生命的人，这里采取了多项措施，包括木制倾斜凹面屏障、安全摄像头和提供24小时危机咨询的电话亭。
Regardless, some reports estimated that up to 50 people killed themselves at the Gap each year by taking the 100m leap into the sea and rocks below. Police headed towards the area and at 8.45pm they found Renee's car parked roughly 150m from the steps at the Gap. Her wallet was inside, along with an old iPhone she'd stopped using two months prior, a Valentine's Day card from Brayden, and a small collage made up of the very few photos that Brayden had sent Renee. Written in the condensation on the car windows were the words, I love you Brayden. Renee's parents were notified and they rushed to the scene in a panic. Renee's car was usually filled with personal items like clothes and makeup, but it struck them as odd that it was now completely empty. As police conducted both land and air searches, Teresa and her husband Mark walked the coastal cliffs and surrounding paths and parklands,
尽管如此，一些报告估计每年有多达50人在“缺口”跳下100米高的悬崖，坠入大海和岩石中自杀。警方前往该地区，并在晚上8点45分发现了蕾妮的车，停在距离“缺口”台阶约150米处。她的钱包在里面，还有一部她两个月前停止使用的旧iPhone，一张来自布雷登的情人节卡片，以及一个由布雷登发给蕾妮的极少数照片组成的小拼贴画。车窗上的冷凝水上写着：“我爱你，布雷登。”蕾妮的父母接到通知，惊慌失措地赶到现场。蕾妮的车里通常装满了衣服和化妆品等个人物品，但现在完全空空如也，这让他们觉得很奇怪。当警方进行陆地和空中搜寻时，特蕾莎和她的丈夫马克走在海岸悬崖和周围的小径及公园里，
shouting Renee's name before the search was called off due to darkness. It resumed the following morning. Sitting neatly near an old gun turret in a reserve known as Jacob's Ladder, Teresa found Renee's black ballet flats. Another air search was conducted while the water police scoured the surrounding sea and three police divers searched the rocky sea floor. Still, there was no sign of Renee. Police made the tragic conclusion that Renee had taken her own life. The waters were clear with a visibility of around 100 metres, leading them to determine that Renee's body would be recovered within three days. Teresa refused to believe that her daughter had suicided, it simply didn't make sense.
大声呼喊蕾妮的名字，直到搜寻因天黑而停止。第二天早上搜寻恢复。在被称为“雅各布阶梯”（Jacob's Ladder）的保护区内，一座旧炮塔附近，特蕾莎整齐地发现了蕾妮的黑色芭蕾平底鞋。警方进行了另一次空中搜寻，水警搜查了周围的海域，三名潜水员搜查了岩石海底。然而，仍然没有蕾妮的踪迹。警方得出了悲剧性的结论，蕾妮已经自杀了。水域清澈，能见度约为100米，这使他们断定蕾妮的遗体将在三天内被找到。特蕾莎拒绝相信女儿自杀了，这根本说不通。
Just two days earlier, Renee had a ball celebrating her cousin's 21st birthday and she was looking forward to her own 21st in a couple months time. She was excited about studying and was making plans to move into the city. If she really had taken her own life, something must have happened to trigger such an out of character decision. Teresa was convinced that Brayden Spatieri held the answer, but despite her efforts, she couldn't get in touch with him. Two days after Renee's disappearance, Teresa sent Brayden several texts asking if he knew where Renee was and demanding answers. There was no reply. Renee's friend Camilla Zidane urged Teresa not to blame Brayden, saying that he was hurting as well. When Teresa asked how she could possibly know this, Camilla explained that on the night Renee went missing, Brayden had called her from a private number.
就在两天前，蕾妮还参加了庆祝她表弟21岁生日的舞会，她还期待着几个月后自己的21岁生日。她对学习感到兴奋，并计划搬到城里去。如果她真的自杀了，一定发生了什么事触发了这种反常的决定。特蕾莎确信布雷登·斯帕蒂里掌握着答案，但尽管她努力尝试，却无法联系到他。蕾妮失踪两天后，特蕾莎给布雷登发了几条短信，询问他是否知道蕾妮在哪里，并要求他给出答案。没有回复。蕾妮的朋友卡米拉·齐达内敦促特蕾莎不要责怪布雷登，说他也很痛苦。当特蕾莎问她怎么可能知道这一点时，卡米拉解释说，在蕾妮失踪的那天晚上，布雷登曾用私人号码给她打过电话。
He was worried about Renee, but didn't want to speak to anyone because he knew he'd get the blame. According to Camilla, Renee had expressed suicidal thoughts in the past, but had promised she'd never act on them. Camilla told Teresa, It didn't have anything to do with Brayden. I think Renee was just an upset person. She always felt like everyone was against her. Police were interested in the role Brayden Spatieri might have played in Renee's disappearance. They gathered phone records and CCTV footage to help piece together Renee's last movements and her final interactions with Brayden. Renee's primary mobile phone was never recovered, therefore the content of the messages couldn't be ascertained. Police attempted to extract the messages from the old iPhone found in Renee's car, but it was protected by a passcode which they couldn't unlock.
他很担心蕾妮，但不想和任何人说话，因为他知道自己会被责怪。据卡米拉说，蕾妮过去曾表达过自杀念头，但承诺过永远不会付诸行动。卡米拉告诉特蕾莎：“这和布雷登没有任何关系。我觉得蕾妮只是一个难过的人。她总是觉得每个人都在针对她。”警方对布雷登·斯帕蒂里在蕾妮失踪中所扮演的角色很感兴趣。他们收集了电话记录和闭路电视录像，以帮助拼凑蕾妮最后的行踪以及她与布雷登的最后互动。蕾妮的主要手机从未被找回，因此无法确定短信的内容。警方试图从蕾妮车里发现的旧iPhone中提取短信，但它被密码保护，他们无法解锁。
Based on the available records, it was ascertained that on the day that Renee died, she and Brayden had exchanged 91 text messages. After Renee assured her mother that she'd ended things with Brayden for good, she continued sending him messages. Brayden didn't reply. Renee then drove towards the gap, arriving at around 5.20pm. There was still no response from Brayden. She texted him again before walking around the area and sitting on a brick wall near the old gun turret. She sent Brayden 5 more messages and at 5.46pm he finally replied. Renee sent Brayden 3 more texts, each of which was met with silence. She then sent a text to her friend, Camilla Zidane. It was followed by the goodbye message to her mother, before Renee removed her shoes and climbed to the nearby fence.
根据现有记录，可以确定在蕾妮去世的那天，她和布雷登交换了91条短信。在蕾妮向母亲保证她已经彻底结束了与布雷登的关系后，她继续给他发信息。布雷登没有回复。蕾妮随后开车前往“缺口”，大约在下午5点20分到达。布雷登仍然没有回应。她在该地区走动并坐在旧炮塔附近的砖墙上之前又给他发了短信。她给布雷登发了5条信息，下午5点46分他终于回复了。蕾妮给布雷登发了3条短信，每一条都石沉大海。然后她给朋友卡米拉·齐达内发了一条短信。随后是给母亲的告别信息，之后蕾妮脱下鞋子，爬上了附近的围栏。
As she glanced over the rocky cliff edge, she received a text from Brayden. Renee replied straight away. Two minutes later, she threw her phone over the cliff before disappearing from view. By the time Brayden wrote back at 5.55pm, Renee was already gone. A phone call Renee had made at 2.44pm was also significant. It appeared that shortly after receiving the text message from Brayden saying that they needed to take a break, Renee had called a goblin prison. What transpired on that 92nd phone call was unknown, but it was possible she'd learnt what the police had come to know for themselves. That there was no inmate at goblin prison named Brayden Spittiri.
当她看向岩石悬崖边缘时，她收到了布雷登的一条短信。蕾妮立即回复。两分钟后，她把手机扔下悬崖，然后消失在视线中。当布雷登在下午5点55分回信时，蕾妮已经不在了。蕾妮在下午2点44分打出的一个电话也很重要。看来在收到布雷登说他们需要休息一下的短信后不久，蕾妮就给古尔本监狱打了个电话。那个92秒的通话内容不得而知，但她可能已经知道了警方自己发现的事实。那就是古尔本监狱里根本没有一个叫布雷登·斯帕蒂里的囚犯。
Fight tough headache and migraine pain two ways. Introducing new Advil Plus Acetaminophen. It combines two of the most trusted pain fighting ingredients into one convenient tablet. Ibuprofen targets pain at the source, and Acetaminophen blocks pain signals, providing fast, effective pain relief for up to eight hours. Conquer headaches fast with the dual action pain fighting relief of new Advil Plus Acetaminophen, now available across Canada. Renee Marsden and Camilla Zidane had been best friends since year nine of high school. During the early stages of their friendship, the Marsden's noticed considerable changes in Renee's behaviour. Renee had always been outspoken and outgoing, but the more time she spent with Camilla, the more withdrawn she became.
用两种方式对抗严重的头痛和偏头痛。隆重推出全新的Advil Plus Acetaminophen。它将两种最值得信赖的止痛成分结合成一片方便的药片。布洛芬从源头靶向疼痛，而对乙酰氨基酚阻断疼痛信号，提供长达八小时的快速、有效的疼痛缓解。用全新Advil Plus Acetaminophen的双重止痛效果快速征服头痛，现已在加拿大各地上市。蕾妮·马斯登和卡米拉·齐达内从高中九年级起就是最好的朋友。在她们友谊的早期阶段，马斯登一家注意到蕾妮的行为发生了相当大的变化。蕾妮一直直言不讳、性格外向，但她和卡米拉在一起的时间越多，就变得越孤僻。
Camilla didn't like Renee's boyfriend at the time, so Renee broke up with him. She started smoking cigarettes and ditching school, with her grades suffering as a result. Renee had always been incredibly close to her cousin Stephanie, who felt that Camilla tried to tear them apart. Renee once confided in Stephanie that Camilla was being violent towards her, sometimes pushing her and punching her hard enough to cause bruises. Stephanie had no reason to doubt this as she'd noticed the controlling behaviour for herself. She'd once been with Renee when Camilla had tried to call her 16 times in a 50 minute period. Stephanie advised Renee to stop seeing Camilla, but the friendship continued. In 2008, Renee made another confession to Stephanie. Camilla had tried to kiss her several times.
卡米拉不喜欢蕾妮当时的男朋友，所以蕾妮和他分手了。她开始抽烟并逃学，导致成绩下滑。蕾妮一直和她的表姐斯蒂芬妮（Stephanie）非常亲近，斯蒂芬妮觉得卡米拉试图拆散她们。蕾妮曾向斯蒂芬妮吐露，卡米拉对她有暴力行为，有时会推她，并用力打她，导致淤青。斯蒂芬妮没有理由怀疑这一点，因为她自己也注意到了这种控制行为。有一次她和蕾妮在一起时，卡米拉在50分钟内试图给她打了16次电话。斯蒂芬妮建议蕾妮停止与卡米拉来往，但友谊仍在继续。2008年，蕾妮向斯蒂芬妮做了另一次坦白。卡米拉曾多次试图亲吻她。
She would alternate between trying to seduce Renee and being violent towards her. Although Renee considered herself heterosexual, the two eventually experimented physically. Renee made it clear that nothing would ever eventuate given that she was straight. But Camilla's feelings were significantly stronger than Renee's. In one email to Renee, Camilla wrote, You got no way to escape, babe, because only I'm in love with you, only I'll own you, and only I'll have you forever. Stephanie told Renee's mother what was going on. Teresa went through Renee's room and found several love letters from Camilla.
她会在试图诱惑蕾妮和对她施暴之间交替。虽然蕾妮认为自己是异性恋，但两人最终在身体上进行了实验。蕾妮明确表示，鉴于她是直的，什么都不会发生。但卡米拉的感情明显比蕾妮强烈得多。在给蕾妮的一封电子邮件中，卡米拉写道：“你没法逃脱，宝贝，因为只有我爱着你，只有我拥有你，只有我永远拥有你。”斯蒂芬妮告诉了蕾妮的母亲发生了什么事。特蕾莎翻遍了蕾妮的房间，发现了卡米拉写的几封情书。
She confronted Renee who admitted to everything and said she was afraid of Camilla. Renee's parents organised meetings with the girls' school and Camilla's parents in a bid to end the friendship, but the two girls continued seeing each other regardless. Camilla even provided Renee with a mobile phone she could use to contact her on exclusively. In 2009, Renee was sick of the way Camilla treated her. She attempted to distance herself by leaving school to study hairdressing. Shortly after, Camilla enrolled in the same course. Renee confided in Stephanie that one day Camilla had chased her down the hall and pulled her hair.
她与蕾妮对质，蕾妮承认了一切，并表示她害怕卡米拉。蕾妮的父母曾组织与学校及卡米拉父母的会面，试图结束这段友谊，但两个女孩依然继续来往。卡米拉甚至给蕾妮提供了一部手机，专门用于两人联系。2009年，蕾妮厌倦了卡米拉对待她的方式。她试图通过退学去学习美发来疏远对方。不久后，卡米拉也报名参加了同一门课程。蕾妮向斯蒂芬妮吐露，有一次卡米拉在走廊里追赶她并拉扯她的头发。
She said she was scared, but didn't know what to do. It was in 2010 that Renee began a relationship with a young man named Angus and tried to put even more space between herself and Camilla. However, Camilla would show up at Renee's workplace uninvited, and Teresa noticed her lurking around outside of the Marsden's home. She had a habit of showing up at the same place as Renee and calling it a coincidence. One day, Renee and Teresa were at the library when Camilla appeared out of nowhere and said, As long as you refuse to answer my phone calls, I will continue to follow you. Renee ultimately dropped out of her hairdressing course to avoid Camilla. She organised a meeting with both of their mothers to let Camilla know she was done with their friendship for good.
她说她很害怕，但不知道该怎么办。2010年，蕾妮开始与一名叫安格斯的年轻人交往，并试图与卡米拉保持更远的距离。然而，卡米拉会不请自来地出现在蕾妮的工作场所，特蕾莎也注意到她在马斯登家门外徘徊。她有一种习惯，总是出现在蕾妮所在的地方，并称之为巧合。有一天，蕾妮和特蕾莎在图书馆时，卡米拉突然出现并说：“只要你拒绝接听我的电话，我就会一直跟着你。”蕾妮最终退出了美发课程以躲避卡米拉。她组织了一次双方母亲的会面，让卡米拉知道她彻底结束了这段友谊。
Camilla became so upset that she physically tried to prevent Renee from leaving, forcing Teresa to intervene. After this, Camilla continued to contact Renee. Renee mostly ignored her until August 2011 when she eventually caved in and the two resumed their friendship. Things didn't improve. One night, Renee received 54 missed calls from Camilla. In a text, Renee wrote, I'm sorry, but that's possessive. If you can't see that, then there is something terribly wrong with you. Undeterred, Camilla continued to make snide remarks about Angus and complained that Renee always treated her second best.
卡米拉非常生气，甚至试图用身体阻拦蕾妮离开，迫使特蕾莎出面干预。此后，卡米拉继续联系蕾妮。蕾妮大多选择无视，直到2011年8月，她最终妥协，两人恢复了友谊。情况并没有好转。一天晚上，蕾妮收到了卡米拉打来的54个未接来电。蕾妮在短信中写道：“对不起，但这太占有欲了。如果你看不出来，那你一定有什么地方出了大问题。”卡米拉并未退缩，继续对安格斯发表刻薄的言论，并抱怨蕾妮总是把她排在第二位。
Renee constantly tried to appease Camilla, but it wasn't enough. At the start of September, Camilla told Renee to make a choice between her and Angus. Renee responded that there would always be another person, if not Angus, then someone else. Two months later, Braden Spittiri entered the picture. Given that Camilla and Braden were close friends, Camilla was privileged to an insider's view of the couple's relationship. When Braden would display jealousy, Camilla would warn Renee not to cheat on him. She was their biggest supporter and always encouraged Renee to remain loyal to Braden and to work through any of their rough patches. As Renee and Braden's relationship progressed, the friendship between Renee and Camilla continued on rocky grounds.
蕾妮不断试图安抚卡米拉，但这还不够。9月初，卡米拉让蕾妮在自己和安格斯之间做出选择。蕾妮回应说，总会有另一个人，如果不是安格斯，也会是别人。两个月后，布雷登·斯皮蒂里出现在了生活中。鉴于卡米拉和布雷登是密友，卡米拉得以从内部视角了解这对情侣的关系。当布雷登表现出嫉妒时，卡米拉会警告蕾妮不要背叛他。她是他们最大的支持者，总是鼓励蕾妮对布雷登保持忠诚，并克服他们之间的任何摩擦。随着蕾妮和布雷登关系的进展，蕾妮和卡米拉之间的友谊依然处于动荡之中。
Periods of closeness were followed by weeks of arguing. Renee made multiple attempts to distance herself, but Camilla always found a way back. In March 2013, Renee confided in Braden that Camilla had hit her and pulled her hair after a night out. She told him that she was done with their friendship for good. Whenever things went sour, Braden typically tried to smooth things over, often taking Camilla's side and telling Renee to be more understanding. Other times, he told Renee to break away from Camilla and find new friends. By June 2013, Renee and Camilla's relationship had become particularly volatile. Camilla was about to embark on a month-long holiday to the United States, and Renee saw this as an opportunity to put some distance between them once and for all.
亲密时期之后往往是数周的争吵。蕾妮多次尝试疏远，但卡米拉总能找到回来的路。2013年3月，蕾妮向布雷登吐露，卡米拉在一次外出后打了她并拉扯了她的头发。她告诉他，她彻底结束了这段友谊。每当事情变糟时，布雷登通常会试图调解，往往站在卡米拉一边，告诉蕾妮要多体谅。有时，他又告诉蕾妮要离开卡米拉，去结交新朋友。到2013年6月，蕾妮和卡米拉的关系变得特别不稳定。卡米拉即将开始为期一个月的美国假期，蕾妮将其视为彻底拉开距离的机会。
She sat her mother down and told her just how bad things had become. In addition to the punching and hair-pulling, Renee said she'd recently been driving when Camilla suddenly ripped the steering wheel from her hands. Renee told Theresa she'd put up with Camilla's abuse for too long and was genuinely frightened of her. In late July, while Camilla was in the USA, Renee sent her a text message saying she was done with their friendship for good. She told Camilla not to contact her upon her return home. Renee was relieved to have cut ties, but it was a lonely time for her, given that Braden also didn't have access to his phone at this time due to his pending parole hearing. She recorded her feelings in a letter to give to Braden later. In it, she said,
她让母亲坐下来，告诉她情况有多糟糕。除了拳打脚踢和拉扯头发，蕾妮说最近她在开车时，卡米拉突然从她手中抢走了方向盘。蕾妮告诉特蕾莎，她忍受卡米拉的虐待太久了，真的非常害怕她。7月下旬，当卡米拉在美国时，蕾妮给她发了一条短信，说她彻底结束了这段友谊。她告诉卡米拉回国后不要联系她。蕾妮为切断了联系感到如释重负，但那段时间她感到很孤独，因为布雷登当时也因等待假释听证会而无法使用手机。她把自己的感受记录在一封信里，打算以后交给布雷登。信中写道：
I can tell you, I have finally let Camilla go for good, and I feel so much better about it now. After discovering there was no inmate by the name of Braden Spatieri at Gulburn Prison, police investigating Renee's disappearance made further inquiries with correctional services, as well as the high school Braden claimed to have attended. There was no record of him anywhere. Either Braden Spatieri had been lying to Renee all along, or he didn't exist at all. Renee's ex-boyfriend Angus had been devastated when Renee abruptly entered their relationship in late 2011. Curious to know more about her new boyfriend, he had looked up a Braden's Facebook profile and noticed that he listed many of the same hobbies and interests as Camilla. Angus reached out to Braden, and the two started chatting back and forth. Anytime Angus asked Braden questions about himself, his answers were vague.
“我可以告诉你，我终于彻底放下了卡米拉，现在感觉好多了。”在发现古尔本监狱并没有名为布雷登·斯皮蒂里的囚犯后，调查蕾妮失踪案的警察向惩教部门以及布雷登声称就读的高中进行了进一步查询。到处都没有他的记录。要么是布雷登·斯皮蒂里一直在欺骗蕾妮，要么他根本就不存在。蕾妮的前男友安格斯在2011年底蕾妮突然结束他们的关系时感到非常痛苦。出于对她新男友的好奇，他查看了布雷登的Facebook个人资料，发现他列出的许多爱好和兴趣与卡米拉相同。安格斯联系了布雷登，两人开始来回聊天。每当安格斯问布雷登关于他自己的问题时，他的回答都很模糊。
He also noticed that Braden's messages shared the same distinct spelling and grammatical errors as the ones he'd seen Camilla send to Renee. Worried that his ex was being duped, he voiced his suspicions to Renee that Braden and Camilla were one and the same. Renee became extremely upset at the allegation and strongly denied the possibility. Angus wasn't the only one with doubt. From early on in Renee and Braden's relationship, Renee's cousin Stephanie had expressed concerns that she didn't think Braden was real. To prove Braden's existence, Renee gave him Stephanie's phone number, and the two began texting back and forth. Stephanie remained dubious. Something about the whole situation didn't feel right.
他还注意到，布雷登的信息中有着与他曾见过卡米拉发给蕾妮的信息相同的拼写和语法错误。担心前女友被骗，他向蕾妮表达了自己的怀疑，认为布雷登和卡米拉其实是同一个人。蕾妮对这一指控感到非常愤怒，并强烈否认这种可能性。安格斯并不是唯一有疑虑的人。从蕾妮和布雷登关系的早期开始，蕾妮的表妹斯蒂芬妮就表达了担忧，她认为布雷登不是真实存在的。为了证明布雷登的存在，蕾妮给了他斯蒂芬妮的电话号码，两人开始互发短信。斯蒂芬妮仍然持怀疑态度。整个情况总觉得哪里不对劲。
Stephanie suspected that Renee was being catfished by Camilla, but she had no evidence to prove it. The skepticism frustrated Renee. She told a work colleague, If I didn't think Braden was real, I wouldn't have left Ian. Renee's parents had ongoing concerns about Camilla's feelings towards their daughter, but they never imagined she'd stoop so low as to create a false online persona just to maintain control over her. Camilla's strange behaviour following Renee's disappearance had them thinking otherwise. She'd been unusually quick to jump to Braden's defence and had no issues with laying the blame for Renee's problems on her family. When the Marsden's asked Camilla to see the last message Renee had sent her, she claimed she'd accidentally deleted it.
斯蒂芬妮怀疑蕾妮被卡米拉“钓鱼”了，但她没有证据证明这一点。这种怀疑让蕾妮感到沮丧。她告诉一位同事：“如果我不认为布雷登是真实的，我就不会离开伊恩。”蕾妮的父母一直担心卡米拉对他们女儿的感情，但他们从未想到她会卑劣到创建一个虚假的在线人格，仅仅是为了维持对她的控制。卡米拉在蕾妮失踪后的奇怪行为让他们有了不同的想法。她异常迅速地跳出来为布雷登辩护，并毫不犹豫地将蕾妮的问题归咎于她的家人。当马斯登夫妇要求卡米拉查看蕾妮发给她的最后一条信息时，她声称自己不小心删除了。
When Theresa told Camilla she'd given Braden's phone number to the police, Camilla panicked and demanded she ask for a back. Although this was odd, it didn't prove anything. The police continued trying to access Renee's old iPhone, but were unable to bypass the security code. Desperate for answers, the Marsden's contacted Renee's mobile service provider and requested a copy of all her text records. However, this data was only held by the company for seven days. By the time they asked for it, it was already too late. On August 25, 2013, three weeks after Renee's disappearance, Camilla Zidane arrived at the police station for a pre-arranged interview. She had been asked to bring some notes about her friendship with Renee, the pair's most recent communications, and her knowledge of Braden's battery. Camilla presented a two-page statement as requested, but it made no mention of Braden.
当特蕾莎告诉卡米拉她已经把布雷登的电话号码交给警察时，卡米拉惊慌失措，要求她要回来。虽然这很奇怪，但并不能证明什么。警方继续尝试访问蕾妮的旧iPhone，但无法绕过安全密码。马斯登夫妇急于寻找答案，联系了蕾妮的移动服务提供商，要求提供她所有的短信记录副本。然而，这些数据公司只保留七天。当他们提出要求时，已经太晚了。2013年8月25日，即蕾妮失踪三周后，卡米拉·齐达内抵达警察局接受预先安排的采访。她被要求带上关于她与蕾妮友谊的笔记、两人最近的通讯记录，以及她对布雷登的了解。卡米拉按要求提交了一份两页的声明，但其中只字未提布雷登。
All it said about her and Renee's most recent communication was that Renee's final text had read, I'm sorry for everything. You will always be my best friend. I hope one day you can forgive me. I love you. Camilla said that she and Braden had met at a nightclub called the Brewery several years prior, but she couldn't recall the exact date. She gave the interviewing officer a description of Braden, but said that Renee never told her anything about their relationship. The officer asked Camilla for Braden's phone number. She said she didn't have it, as it was saved on her phone which was broken and currently being repaired. As the interview wound up, the officer looked at Camilla and said, I want you to be honest with me. The telephone call logs that I have here in front of me suggest to me that you are Braden. Are you?
关于她和蕾妮最近的通讯，声明中只写道蕾妮的最后一条短信是：“对不起，一切都是我的错。你永远是我最好的朋友。希望有一天你能原谅我。我爱你。”卡米拉说，她和布雷登几年前在一家名为“啤酒厂”的夜总会相识，但她记不清确切日期。她向采访警官描述了布雷登，但表示蕾妮从未告诉过她关于他们关系的任何事情。警官向卡米拉索要布雷登的电话号码。她说她没有，因为号码保存在她那部坏了且正在维修的手机里。采访快结束时，警官看着卡米拉说：“我希望你对我诚实。我面前的通话记录显示，你就是布雷登。你是吗？”
When Camilla was confronted with the suggestion that she was really Braden's battery, she replied, No, I know that a lot of people think I am. Everyone is against me. I wish I was where Renee is now, wherever she is. I just want to have the peace she is feeling now. On September 23, almost one month after her first interview, police arrived at Camilla's home armed with a search warrant. They seized three phones, but couldn't find the SIM card associated with Braden's battery's phone number. In a rubbish bin, they found a letter written from Renee to Braden, but it had been torn to shreds. They also found a letter that Renee had written to Camilla in March 2013, in which she thanked Camilla for introducing her to Braden. Renee wrote,
当卡米拉被指控她实际上就是布雷登时，她回答说：“不，我知道很多人都认为是我。每个人都反对我。我真希望我现在就在蕾妮所在的地方，无论她在哪里。我只想拥有她现在感受到的那种平静。”9月23日，在第一次采访近一个月后，警察带着搜查令抵达卡米拉家。他们查获了三部手机，但没能找到与布雷登电话号码相关的SIM卡。在垃圾桶里，他们发现了一封蕾妮写给布雷登的信，但已被撕成碎片。他们还发现了一封蕾妮在2013年3月写给卡米拉的信，信中她感谢卡米拉将布雷登介绍给她。蕾妮写道：
You don't understand, babe, how much it truly means to me. If it wasn't because of you, I wouldn't have met the one person that means more than the world itself to me. I'll do anything I can to make sure I can give you what I found, and make sure that person is your all. It's my life mission to see you happy, and my life won't fully be complete until I see the day you have everything you have ever dreamt of. As the officers were leaving Camilla's bedroom, one of them turned to her and asked if there was anything she'd like to talk about. Camilla paused. She then admitted, I was sending the text messages to Renee before I left for America. Renee asked me to. She wanted me to pretend that I was Braden. The officer asked why, to which Camilla responded.
“宝贝，你不知道这对我来说意味着什么。如果不是因为你，我就不会遇到那个对我来说比整个世界都重要的人。我会尽我所能确保我能给你我所找到的一切，并确保那个人是你的一切。看到你幸福是我的人生使命，在我看到你拥有你梦想的一切之前，我的人生将永远不会完整。”当警察离开卡米拉的卧室时，其中一人转向她，问她是否有话要说。卡米拉停顿了一下。然后她承认：“我在去美国之前一直在给蕾妮发短信。是蕾妮让我这么做的。她想让我假装是布雷登。”警官问为什么，卡米拉回答道：
I don't know, I just did it because she wanted me to. I didn't do anything else. She then asked, what's going to happen to me? The officer replied, At this stage Camilla, we are just interested in finding out what has happened to Renee. The police attempted to download the contents of the three phones seized from Camilla, but they didn't reveal much. Camilla had already deleted a majority of the communication between herself and Renee, including the final messages sent between them on Monday, August 5. However, she did have the photo of herself and Braden saved on one of the devices, the sole photo that Renee had of Braden's face. Camilla eventually admitted that she didn't know the man in the photo. It had just been taken at random in a nightclub.
“我不知道，我只是因为她想让我这么做才做的。我没做过其他任何事。”然后她问：“我会怎么样？”警官回答说：“现阶段，卡米拉，我们只是想找出蕾妮发生了什么事。”警方试图下载从卡米拉那里查获的三部手机的内容，但并没有发现太多信息。卡米拉已经删除了她和蕾妮之间的大部分通讯记录，包括8月5日星期一两人之间发送的最后信息。然而，她确实在其中一台设备上保存了她和布雷登的照片，这是蕾妮拥有的唯一一张布雷登脸部的照片。卡米拉最终承认她并不认识照片中的那个人。那只是在夜总会随机拍摄的。
After three months of unsuccessfully trying to crack into Renee's old iPhone, the police returned it to the Marsden family. As reported by Channel 9's Australian Crime Stories, Renee's 13-year-old brother Luke had a friend who thought they could crack into the phone. All they needed to do was purchase an app for $100. The Marsdens immediately handed over their credit card details, and within 10 minutes, they were in. Suddenly, they had access to countless messages. Over the three-month period from April to June 2013 alone, 11,000 text messages had been sent between Renee and Braden and Renee and Camilla. However, the texts were all scrambled. Renee's father, Mark, began the long and arduous task of slowly unscrambling each and every one, and then attempting to piece them together.
在尝试破解蕾妮的旧iPhone三个月未果后，警方将其归还给了马斯登一家。据第九频道的《澳大利亚犯罪故事》报道，蕾妮13岁的弟弟卢克有一位朋友认为他们可以破解这部手机。他们只需要花100美元买一个应用程序。马斯登夫妇立即交出了信用卡信息，10分钟内，他们就进入了手机。突然，他们可以访问无数的信息。仅在2013年4月至6月这三个月期间，蕾妮与布雷登以及蕾妮与卡米拉之间就发送了11,000条短信。然而，这些短信都是乱码。蕾妮的父亲马克开始了缓慢而艰巨的任务，将每一条短信逐一解码，然后试图将它们拼凑起来。
As Mark entered the dates and messages into a computer document, he noticed that a pattern started to emerge. At no point did Camilla and Braden both converse with Renee at the same time. Renee would engage with one of them before texting with the other, but the conversations never overlapped. This was consistent with another detail that had been raised. In early 2012, Braden had been out of communication with Renee while he underwent surgery. This just so happened to align with the time while Camilla was away on holiday. Likewise, Camilla's most recent trip to the United States had coincided with the month that Braden went off-grid as he told Renee he awaited his parole hearing. Theresa Marsden struggled to accept the fact that her daughter was really gone.
当马克将日期和信息输入电脑文档时，他注意到一种模式开始显现。卡米拉和布雷登从未在同一时间与蕾妮交谈。蕾妮会先与其中一人互动，然后再与另一人发短信，但对话从未重叠。这与之前提出的另一个细节相吻合。2012年初，布雷登在接受手术期间与蕾妮失去了联系。这恰好与卡米拉外出度假的时间吻合。同样，卡米拉最近的美国之行也与布雷登告诉蕾妮他正在等待假释听证会而“离线”的那个月重合。特蕾莎·马斯登难以接受女儿真的离开了的事实。
Given that Renee's body was never discovered, Theresa continued to hold on to hope that she hadn't really killed herself, but had moved away to escape the threats from Camilla. Theresa distributed missing person posters all the way up the New South Wales coastline and into Queensland, hoping that Renee would pick up the phone or walk through the door. Even though the police began preparing a report for the coroner, Theresa still couldn't comprehend it. She told the Daily Mail, It's different if you see a body, but there's too much evidence to suggest she's alive. There's no evidence to suspect she's not here. In 2019, six years after Renee Marsden's disappearance, advances in technology finally made it possible for law enforcement to have full access to the contents of Renee and Braden's text messages. With the full nature of their relationship clear at last, there was no doubt that Camilla Zidane had been behind the Braden Spittiri persona all along. At one point, Braden had even encouraged Renee to have sex with Camilla as a way to get some of her anger out, a suggestion which Renee met with a firm no. The act of assuming a fake online identity in order to target a specific victim is known as catfishing.
鉴于蕾妮的尸体从未被发现，特蕾莎继续怀抱希望，认为她并没有自杀，而是搬走以逃避卡米拉的威胁。特蕾莎在新南威尔士州海岸线一直到昆士兰州分发失踪人员海报，希望蕾妮能接听电话或走进家门。尽管警方开始为验尸官准备报告，但特蕾莎仍然无法理解。她告诉《每日邮报》：“看到尸体是另一回事，但有太多的证据表明她还活着。没有证据怀疑她不在这里。”2019年，在蕾妮·马斯登失踪六年之后，技术的进步终于使执法部门能够完全访问蕾妮和布雷登的短信内容。随着他们关系的全部真相终于大白，毫无疑问，卡米拉·齐达内一直以来都是布雷登·斯皮蒂里这个角色的幕后黑手。有一次，布雷登甚至鼓励蕾妮与卡米拉发生性关系，以此作为发泄愤怒的一种方式，蕾妮对此坚决拒绝。这种为了针对特定受害者而假冒在线身份的行为被称为“钓鱼”。
Catfishing itself isn't considered a criminal offence in Australia unless it's done for the purpose of an illegal act, such as fraud, financial gain, stalking, or the grooming of underage persons. Even though Camilla Zidane was clearly Braden Spittiri, she hadn't used the fake account for any of these punishable offences. Therefore, there was nothing that New South Wales police could charge her with. A criminal lawyer told a current affair, Unfortunately, catfishing in most circumstances is probably best defined as a crime of the heart. Although Teresa eventually accepted that Renee had passed away, she needed answers. She requested that a coronial inquest be conducted to determine the true role that Camilla's actions played in Renee's suicide. The final messages sent between them remained a mystery, and the Marsden's wanted to know if Renee had found out about Braden's true identity before deciding to end her own life.
在澳大利亚，“钓鱼”本身并不被视为刑事犯罪，除非它是为了非法行为，如欺诈、经济利益、跟踪或诱骗未成年人。尽管卡米拉·齐达内显然就是布雷登·斯皮蒂里，但她并没有利用这个虚假账户进行任何这些可惩罚的罪行。因此，新南威尔士州警方没有任何理由起诉她。一位刑事律师告诉《时事》节目：“不幸的是，在大多数情况下，钓鱼最好被定义为一种‘心灵犯罪’。”尽管特蕾莎最终接受了蕾妮已经去世的事实，但她需要答案。她要求进行验尸调查，以确定卡米拉的行为在蕾妮自杀中扮演的真实角色。两人之间发送的最后信息仍然是一个谜，马斯登夫妇想知道蕾妮在决定结束自己的生命之前是否发现了布雷登的真实身份。
It was a long, drawn-out process, but Camilla Zidane eventually struck a deal that ensured she wouldn't face prosecution if she appeared at an inquest. This meant that anything she said in court couldn't be used against her for future charges. As the inquest commenced in February 2020, the Marsden family held high hopes that they'd finally get answers to the questions that had been plaguing them for the past seven years. The now 27-year-old Camilla Zidane had since moved on with her life, getting married and starting a family. Given that she'd been granted immunity, the Marsden's hoped that at the very least, she would tell the truth about the final conversations between Renee and Braden. If nothing else, they felt they deserved that closure. Giving evidence over two days, Camilla denied any of the obsessive behavior she'd been accused of. She denied ever following Renee, lurking outside of her house, or calling her excessively.
这是一个漫长而拖沓的过程，但卡米拉·齐达内最终达成了一项协议，确保如果她在调查中出庭，她就不会面临起诉。这意味着她在法庭上所说的任何话都不能用于未来的指控。随着2020年2月调查的开始，马斯登一家怀着极大的希望，认为他们终于能得到过去七年来一直困扰他们的问题的答案。现年27岁的卡米拉·齐达内已经继续她的生活，结婚并组建了家庭。鉴于她获得了豁免权，马斯登一家希望至少她能说出蕾妮和布雷登之间最后对话的真相。如果说还有什么的话，他们觉得他们理应得到那个了结。在为期两天的作证中，卡米拉否认了她被指控的所有强迫行为。她否认曾经跟踪蕾妮、在她的房子外徘徊或过度给她打电话。
When presented with some of the intense texts and emails she had sent over the course of their friendship, Camilla reasoned that she had simply loved and cared about Renee. Camilla admitted to playing the role of Braden's pateri, but explained it was because she and Renee were having a romantic relationship. They thought their families wouldn't approve, so they created the character of Braden as a cover-up. According to Camilla, Renee had played an equal part in the charade, helping to set up a Braden's phone and SIM card so the two could communicate in secret. Renee had chosen the photo they used of Braden, cropping Camilla out of it and then sending it to herself as part of the ruse. The coroner presented Camilla with numerous pieces of evidence retrieved from Renee's old iPhone that challenged her claims. If Renee was in on the act, why had she called Gulben Prison and written to the Greek consulate asking if a convicted criminal could obtain a holiday visa? Why would she fight with Braden about wanting to speak to his lawyer and visit the storage unit if she knew such things didn't exist?
当被出示她在友谊期间发送的一些激烈的短信和电子邮件时，卡米拉辩称她只是爱和关心蕾妮。卡米拉承认扮演了布雷登的角色，但解释说这是因为她和蕾妮正在谈恋爱。他们认为家人不会赞同，所以他们创造了布雷登这个角色作为掩护。据卡米拉说，蕾妮在这一骗局中扮演了平等的角色，帮助设置了布雷登的手机和SIM卡，以便两人可以秘密交流。蕾妮选择了他们使用的布雷登的照片，将卡米拉从照片中裁剪出来，然后将其发送给自己，作为诡计的一部分。验尸官向卡米拉出示了从蕾妮旧iPhone中检索到的众多证据，这些证据挑战了她的说法。如果蕾妮参与其中，为什么她会打电话给古尔本监狱，并写信给希腊领事馆询问罪犯是否可以获得旅游签证？如果她知道这些事情不存在，为什么她会因为想和他的律师谈话以及参观储物单元而与布雷登争吵？
Why would she have booked an appointment with a wedding photographer and sent Braden photographs of brides and grooms if she knew such a wedding could never go ahead? Renee had sent Braden sexual images of herself and then gotten upset when he refused to reciprocate. She had also written numerous messages that contradicted Camilla's claims. One text read, Do you ever wonder how strange it is that we have never met but we have this inseparable love for each other? Another said, Braden, you will never get it because you're a male but to a girl finding that perfect someone is everything. Camilla's explanation for all of this was that Renee had simply been in character.
如果她知道这样的婚礼永远无法举行，为什么她会预约婚礼摄影师并给布雷登发送新娘和新郎的照片？蕾妮曾给布雷登发送过自己的性暗示图片，并在他拒绝回应时感到不安。她还写了许多与卡米拉的说法相矛盾的信息。一条短信写道：“你有没有觉得很奇怪，我们从未见过面，但我们却对彼此有着不可分割的爱？”另一条写道：“布雷登，你永远不会明白，因为你是男性，但对女孩来说，找到那个完美的人就是一切。”卡米拉对这一切的解释是，蕾妮只是在演戏。
The counsel assisting the coroner told Camilla, You are saying that today but it does not make sense. You wanted Renee to yourself and creating Braden was the perfect opportunity because it meant you could have her all to yourself. Back in August 2013, just days after Camilla returned from the United States, she participated in a soccer match. Renee typically attended Camilla's soccer games and Camilla would get upset if she didn't pay attention. On this occasion, Renee told her mother she would never go to another game because she didn't want to see Camilla. The coroner concluded that Camilla likely interpreted Renee's absence as proof that she was serious about ending their friendship. With her pride hurt, the next day she, quote,
协助验尸官的律师告诉卡米拉：“你今天这么说，但这说不通。你想独占蕾妮，而创造布雷登是一个完美的机会，因为这意味着你可以完全拥有她。”回到2013年8月，就在卡米拉从美国回来几天后，她参加了一场足球比赛。蕾妮通常会参加卡米拉的足球比赛，如果蕾妮不注意，卡米拉会感到不高兴。在那次比赛中，蕾妮告诉母亲她再也不会去参加任何比赛了，因为她不想见到卡米拉。验尸官得出结论，卡米拉很可能将蕾妮的缺席解读为她认真想要结束友谊的证据。第二天，她的自尊心受挫，她引用：
Exacted her ultimate revenge by having Braden break Renee's heart. The Braden-Renee relationship ended as it had started. At Camilla's will. Camilla appeared completely unaffected as she told the court she had no recollection of what was said in those final text messages between Braden and Renee. The only thing she remembered was that Renee was talking about her lack of purpose in life. Camilla claimed she had no idea that Renee had driven to the gap on August 5, 2013, nor that she was serious about threatening to kill herself. The inquest ran for four days and it took four months for the coroner to sift through the abundance of evidence before reaching their conclusion. The findings were handed down on May 20, 2020.
“通过让布雷登伤透蕾妮的心，实施了她最终的报复。”布雷登与蕾妮的关系以开始的方式结束了。按照卡米拉的意愿。当卡米拉告诉法庭她不记得布雷登和蕾妮之间最后那些短信的内容时，她看起来完全不受影响。她唯一记得的是蕾妮在谈论她生活中缺乏目标。卡米拉声称她不知道蕾妮在2013年8月5日开车去了“缺口”（The Gap），也不知道她真的威胁要自杀。调查持续了四天，验尸官花了四个月时间梳理了大量证据，才得出结论。调查结果于2020年5月20日公布。
The coroner described Camilla's idea as disingenuous at best and called her evidence nothing but a pack of lies. From the evidence, it was clear to the coroner that Camilla wanted Renee all to herself. She created the persona of Braden to manipulate and control Renee and to free herself of the jealousy she felt whenever Renee was in a relationship with a man. As for whether or not Renee discovered that Braden was really Camilla, the coroner concluded, I am of the view that Renee likely did not learn of this. Camilla did not tell her because she is unable to admit to having engaged in such a pollen conduct involving such an extreme betrayal of trust of her friend. These communications indicate Renee was very much of the view that Braden was not only real, but certainly not Camilla. In most Australian jurisdictions, it is a criminal offence to encourage someone to take their own life.
验尸官将卡米拉的想法描述为“充其量是虚伪的”，并称她的证词“不过是一堆谎言”。从证据来看，验尸官很清楚卡米拉想独占蕾妮。她创造了布雷登这个角色来操纵和控制蕾妮，并让自己从蕾妮与男人交往时感到的嫉妒中解脱出来。至于蕾妮是否发现布雷登其实是卡米拉，验尸官总结道：“我认为蕾妮很可能没有发现这一点。卡米拉没有告诉她，因为她无法承认自己参与了这种涉及对朋友极度背叛信任的卑劣行为。这些通讯表明，蕾妮非常认为布雷登不仅是真实的，而且肯定不是卡米拉。”在大多数澳大利亚司法管辖区，鼓励他人自杀是刑事犯罪。
Although Camilla knew that Renee would be devastated by the breakup with Braden, the coroner concluded that by destroying the evidence of what was said between them that day, there was no basis to prove that Camilla had incited Renee's suicide. The coroner accepted it was likely true that Camilla didn't know that Renee had driven to the gap on the evening of August 5, 2013, or that she was serious about the suicide threats. Phone records confirmed that Camilla had been casually texting back and forth with other friends at the same time she was interacting with Renee as Braden and was therefore distracted and, quote, untouched by Renee's distress. Although the coroner stopped short of blaming Camilla for inciting Renee's suicide, they did accept that Camilla had, quote, caused the hurt and heartbreak that led Renee to take her own life.
尽管卡米拉知道蕾妮会因为与布雷登分手而崩溃，但验尸官得出结论，由于销毁了那天两人之间谈话的证据，没有依据证明卡米拉煽动了蕾妮的自杀。验尸官接受了卡米拉可能确实不知道蕾妮在2013年8月5日晚上开车去了“缺口”，也不知道她对自杀威胁是认真的。电话记录证实，卡米拉在以布雷登身份与蕾妮互动的同时，也在与其他朋友随意发短信，因此她分心了，并且引用“未受蕾妮痛苦的影响”。尽管验尸官没有指责卡米拉煽动蕾妮自杀，但他们确实承认卡米拉引用“造成了导致蕾妮结束自己生命的伤害和心碎”。
The New South Wales domestic violence death review team had recently released a report that suggested widening the scope of state laws to cover nonviolent types of domestic harm. The coroner recommended that the domestic violence team consider Renee's case in order to help progress their report. By doing so, it was possible that new coercive control laws could be implemented that would apply to individuals who engaged in similar conduct to Camilla's idea. This would essentially make catfishing a punishable offence similar to intimidation and stalking. The coroner noted that Camilla showed no warmth or regard to the Marsden family and that she wasn't concerned about anything except furthering her own fiction, quote. Camilla displayed a deplorable lack of kindness to Renee's family by the lies she told, seeking to cast blame upon them for Renee's unhappiness. I can only hope that this inquest has given them some degree of comfort that Renee's experience is documented and understood. Renee had her entire life to look forward to and it ended all too soon in unnecessary emotional turmoil and trauma.
新南威尔士州家庭暴力死亡审查小组最近发布了一份报告，建议扩大州法律的范围，以涵盖非暴力的家庭伤害类型。验尸官建议家庭暴力小组考虑蕾妮的案例，以帮助推进他们的报告。通过这样做，可能会实施新的强制控制法，适用于从事与卡米拉类似行为的个人。这本质上将使“钓鱼”成为类似于恐吓和跟踪的可惩罚罪行。验尸官指出，卡米拉对马斯登一家没有表现出任何温暖或尊重，除了推进她自己的虚构故事外，她不关心任何事情，引用：“卡米拉通过她所说的谎言，试图将蕾妮的不幸归咎于她的家人，表现出对蕾妮家人令人遗憾的缺乏善意。我只能希望这次调查能给他们某种程度的安慰，即蕾妮的经历已被记录和理解。蕾妮本有整个人生可以期待，却过早地在不必要的心理动荡和创伤中结束了。”
I offer Renee's family and friends my sincere condolences. The Marsden family were crushed by Camilla's ongoing lies. As Renee's cousin Stephanie later told Australian crime stories, they couldn't comprehend why Camilla couldn't have at least met them halfway, quote. Even if she didn't want to tell us everything, she could have at least told us 50% or 60% of what really happened in the end. Outside court, Theresa Marsden told reporters, To some extent, going through the inquiry and going through the findings today is just as bad as when we first heard about Renee going missing. Renee hasn't died in vain, I'll make sure of that. We can't allow this to happen to any other kid. We have to protect other victims.
“我向蕾妮的家人和朋友表示诚挚的慰问。”马斯登一家被卡米拉持续的谎言压垮了。正如蕾妮的表妹斯蒂芬妮后来告诉《澳大利亚犯罪故事》的那样，他们无法理解为什么卡米拉至少不能在中间与他们会合，引用：“即使她不想告诉我们一切，她至少可以告诉我们最终真相的50%或60%。”在法庭外，特蕾莎·马斯登告诉记者：“在某种程度上，经历这次调查和今天的调查结果，和我们第一次听说蕾妮失踪时一样糟糕。蕾妮没有白白死去，我会确保这一点。我们不能让这种事发生在任何其他孩子身上。我们必须保护其他受害者。”
In 2017, a law was passed in Australia that made it illegal for an adult to use a carriage service to engage with minors for the purpose of sexual activity. As covered in episode 91 of Case File, it was named Carly's Law after adult teenager Carly Ryan was murdered by a 50 year old man who catfished her online, pretending to be an 18 year old. Inspired by this, the Marsden family began campaigning to make catfishing a criminal offence when it is done with the intention of causing pain and suffering. The coroner's report supported the consideration of such a law, noting, If Renee discovered that her relationship with Brayden was but a fiction and she took her own life as a consequence, the community might consider that catfishing is an act which should be prohibited. Even if Renee did not discover that Camilla had committed the deception and was simply heartbroken because Brayden had ended the relationship, she has taken her life about a person who does not exist. That consequence is of such gravity that the community would expect to be sanctioned. Dubbing the offence Renee's Law, Theresa started an online petition on change.org calling for catfishers to be held legally accountable for their actions.
2017年，澳大利亚通过了一项法律，规定成年人使用通信服务与未成年人进行性活动是非法的。正如《案件档案》第91集所报道的那样，它以“卡莉法”命名，因为成年少女卡莉·瑞安被一名50岁的男子谋杀，该男子在网上钓鱼她，假装是18岁。受此启发，马斯登一家开始开展运动，将以造成痛苦和折磨为目的的“钓鱼”定为刑事犯罪。验尸官的报告支持考虑这样一项法律，指出：“如果蕾妮发现她与布雷登的关系只是虚构的，并因此结束了自己的生命，社区可能会认为钓鱼是一种应该被禁止的行为。即使蕾妮没有发现卡米拉实施了欺骗，仅仅因为布雷登结束了这段关系而心碎，她也是为了一个不存在的人结束了自己的生命。这种后果的严重性是社区所期望受到制裁的。”特蕾莎在change.org上发起了一份在线请愿书，将该罪行命名为“蕾妮法”，呼吁让钓鱼者对其行为承担法律责任。
The petition states, Renee had a beautiful heart that radiated love to anyone who knew her. Ultimately, her amazing personal qualities left her vulnerable to someone with malicious intent. Renee was lured into a trap set by someone who knew her best and she's not alone. With social media dominating people's lives today, we find many others in similar situations. We will not let Renee leave us in vain. Innocent people need to know they are protected by the law from the cruelty of catfishers. In the lead-up to the inquest, 31-year-old carpenter Cameron had been going about his day when a friend sent him a link to a news story about Renee's case. Cameron froze when he saw the image of Camilla Zidane with the man she told Renee was Brayden Spatieri. The man in the image was Cameron.
请愿书写道：“蕾妮有一颗美丽的心，向任何认识她的人散发着爱。最终，她惊人的个人品质使她容易受到恶意之人的伤害。蕾妮被一个最了解她的人设下的陷阱所诱惑，她并不孤单。随着社交媒体在当今人们生活中占据主导地位，我们发现许多其他人也处于类似的情况。我们不会让蕾妮白白离开我们。无辜的人需要知道他们受到法律保护，免受钓鱼者的残忍伤害。”在调查开始前，31岁的木匠卡梅伦正在过着他的日子，这时一位朋友发给他一个关于蕾妮案件的新闻故事链接。当卡梅伦看到卡米拉·齐达内与她告诉蕾妮是布雷登·斯皮蒂里的男人的照片时，他惊呆了。照片中的男人正是卡梅伦。
Cameron had never met Camilla or Renee before and had no recollection of the photo ever being taken. Judging by how young he looked, he assumed it was a promotional image taken at a nightclub when he was in his early twenties. Realising his image had been used to help catfish a young woman, Cameron felt sick. He didn't want to leave the house, fearful that someone would recognise him and wrongfully think he was involved with Renee's death. The anxiety plagued him and he eventually reached out to the Mastons via Facebook. As Theresa told SBS's Insight, she was reluctant to meet with Cameron at first. Although she felt sorry for him, she just couldn't separate his face from her family's tragedy. After meeting, however, they formed a bond.
卡梅伦以前从未见过卡米拉或蕾妮，也不记得拍过这张照片。从他看起来有多年轻来判断，他认为这是他在二十出头时在夜总会拍摄的宣传照。意识到自己的形象被用来帮助钓鱼一个年轻女性，卡梅伦感到恶心。他不想离开家，害怕有人会认出他，并错误地认为他与蕾妮的死有关。这种焦虑困扰着他，他最终通过Facebook联系了马斯登一家。正如特蕾莎告诉SBS的《洞察》节目那样，她起初不愿与卡梅伦见面。虽然她为他感到难过，但她就是无法将他的脸与她家庭的悲剧分开。然而，在见面后，他们建立了联系。
Cameron is now close with the Mastons and they continue to stay in touch. The photo taken at the nightclub is the only photo of Cameron used in the catfishing ruse. Where the cropped selfies of Brayden's torso and muscles sent to Renee came from is unknown. A secondary victim to Camilla's actions, Cameron supports the Mastons' endeavours to make catfishing illegal. He told a current affair, It's daunting. I'm shocked in a way because I've now got an image put out there that's an image no one wants to be associated with. As of 2023, the Mastons are still fighting to have Renee's law considered by politicians. A link to the petition can be found in the show notes of this episode.
卡梅伦现在与马斯登一家关系密切，他们继续保持联系。在夜总会拍摄的照片是卡梅伦被用于钓鱼诡计的唯一照片。发送给蕾妮的布雷登躯干和肌肉的裁剪自拍照来源不明。作为卡米拉行为的次要受害者，卡梅伦支持马斯登一家将钓鱼定为非法的努力。他告诉《时事》节目：“这令人望而生畏。我感到震惊，因为我现在的形象被发布出去了，这是没人想与之关联的形象。”截至2023年，马斯登一家仍在争取让政客们考虑“蕾妮法”。请愿书的链接可以在本集的节目说明中找到。
Following the inquest, Renee's cousin Stephanie voiced her opinion in a Facebook post. She spoke of Renee's kindness, generosity and the ongoing support she provided to those around her. Beautiful inside and out, Stephanie believed it was these traits that made Renee susceptible to such malicious crimes. She wrote, In today's society with the dominance of social media, we find many people in similar situations as Renee. It's not a lack of intelligence or being gullible that make you a victim of catfishing, particularly when you are as accepting and loving as our dear Renee. Unfortunately, it's good people that get taken advantage of. Renee was an individual who deserved to live a full life and not be robbed of such simple pleasures and freedom.
调查结束后，蕾妮的表妹斯蒂芬妮在Facebook帖子中表达了她的观点。她谈到了蕾妮的善良、慷慨以及她对周围人的持续支持。斯蒂芬妮认为，正是这些内外兼修的美好品质使蕾妮容易受到这种恶意犯罪的伤害。她写道：“在当今社会，随着社交媒体的主导地位，我们发现许多人处于与蕾妮类似的情况。成为钓鱼受害者并不是因为缺乏智慧或轻信，特别是当你像我们亲爱的蕾妮一样乐于接受和充满爱心时。不幸的是，正是好人被利用了。蕾妮是一个值得过上充实生活的人，不应该被剥夺如此简单的快乐和自由。”
Her only guilt would be that she loved too easily and lived life with her heart on her sleeve. Thank you for watching. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
“她唯一的‘罪过’就是爱得太容易，并且活得坦诚。感谢观看。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。”